the Joe Rogan experience you know but
he's got a different fight in front of
him this weekend with Jon Jones Jon
Jones has such a history of success
against the best fighters on the planet
Jon finds a way to win he does man he
finds a way and it's like that was the
good thing about that Gustafson fight
the first one it was such a but I if I
remember right
Jones really turned it on in rounds 4 &
5 like I thought Gustafson was ahead
maybe two to one and then rounds four
and five Jones won yeah again I don't
know if that's a correct recollection
but I remember being like [ __ ] that's
why he's a champion he won the final
round five for sure and he wasn't even
in shape he didn't train for that fight
they said he just [ __ ] off and was
partying and having a good time he just
thought he was under be unbeatable and
he said something really interesting to
me when he came in here he said he
always gave himself an excuse so that
like if he did lose he could always say
well you know what at least I didn't
train right like if I trained then I
would have beat that guy but he was
still beating people even though he
wasn't training hard and then he started
ramping it up and actually training hard
and when he almost lost everything you
know when he got arrested and all that
[ __ ] that happened to him and he almost
lost his career then when it came back
he had much more of a sense of urgency
because he realized like what a gift it
really was yeah I'm happy he's back too
and I honestly after that when I was out
there with Matt and after they they told
us that gone been the fights not
happening I thought like he's never
gonna watch him fight again he'll never
fight again I thought so too when he
crashed in that lady's car and took off
I was like oh my god he might go to jail
and you know I just felt bad that he was
doing that in the first place just all
of it everything was wrong yeah there's
too much partying but sometimes someone
needs some sort of a giant scarab all
series of events where you realize like
oh I can't I can't do this anymore I
gotta live my life in a better way yeah
you have to almost have everything taken
away from you but I believe that Dominic
Reyes is the most dangerous fighter John
Jones has faced since Daniel Cormier I
think Dominic Reyes presents a very
unique series of challenges first of all
the length the undefeated record he's 12
and oh there's confidence that comes
with undefeated fighters Adamic is
extremely
he's he's a believer in himself and that
belief in himself has led him to stop
guys like Chris Weidman to knock out OSP
with one second to go
he's got belief in his power he's got
legit one punch knockout power he's got
great footwork and movement he just had
the opportunity to see John struggle
with Thiago Santos he has a style he can
mimic that kind of success that the
chopping at the legs I think this is a
dangerous fight for John but I also
think John knows it's a dangerous fight
for John and John is a champion a real
champion the greatest champion the light
heavyweight division has ever known
unquestionably and I think he's gonna
rise to the occasion I think we're gonna
see the best John Jones I think John
Jones needs a real threat to scare him
and work him up and I don't know if
Thiago Santos was that for him Megan
Jaco Santos was a title defense a chance
for him to fight but I don't think I
don't think that's what he gets scared
of I think John needs someone like a
Dominic Reyes a real threat so that you
see who he was in the second fight with
Daniel Cormier and when he head kick DC
and knocked him out the second fight
with Gustav and Gustafson when he
smashed down that's the real John Jones
John Jones when he when he's pressed and
I think that Dominic Reyes presents that
kind of a problem and I think you're
gonna see a [ __ ] killer John Jones
next weekend I think he's gonna be on
fire I can't wait that's a week from
Saturday
yeah I can't we're so pumped the moment
I stopped feeling like this I'll stop
calling fights but right now man I
[ __ ] love it there's always fights I
want to see always fights I want to see
there's always something I'm looking
forward to there's never not two or
three fights on the horizon that I want
to see
[Applause]